the Joe Rogan experience I don't know I
haven't been watching TV like the news
you just brought up three things he sees
going on Seattle with the [ __ ] FCC
what if he says I don't know I don't
know what it is
what is Tifa antifoam they call
themselves anti-fascists and they're
they wear masks and carry sticks and
helmets and [ __ ] and intimidate people
exactly they stop fascism they use
faster you know like stop fascism yeah
and they blocked off I think six blocks
of Seattle and they declared it a police
free zone
this is occupied by the people of
Seattle and you can't use money in that
police freeze now Joe I'm gonna go out
on a limb and say that's not gonna end
well that's the only thing that's gonna
keep it from ending badly
is it Seattle is kind of a [ __ ] up
City they tolerate a lot of homelessness
so Seattle's got a lot of weird laws
like it's a it's a I forget the way it's
described I think it's a mutual combat
State that's what's described so like if
you're in front of a cop say if say if
I'm a cop and you and Jamie decided Duke
it out you can just say you want to
fight [ __ ] and yeah I want to
fight and the cops will let you fight
because it's some Wild West mining [ __ ]
from like the [ __ ] 1600 settles it's
like man the books no lawsuits I like it
you can Duke it out in the middle of
street it's very dangerous though people
getting knocked out on the street is
[ __ ] terrifying because they've
fallen they hit their head and they go
unconscious and there's no ref to stop
those last nine Hamlet's I think the
cops are supposed to do that the cops
are supposed to act as a referee to this
[ __ ] there's videos of guys getting into
street fights in Seattle and cops just
standing around watching yeah it's real
weird in fact I don't have a problem if
two people are willing to do it and
they're there they know the risks you
know if you get hit you're gonna fall
and crack your head on the back of the
the curb there I mean a lot of them are
drunk though they don't know the risks
there was one of them this is this kid I
think his last name is Fedor I think
Carlos photo or he was a MMA fighter and
he would dress up like a superhero
what see we can find out what do you
remember his name
anyway he actually knew how to fight and
he was dressed like a superhero so he's
kind of baiting people to [ __ ] with him
and he's walking on the street and these
[ __ ] with hilarious they decide to go at
it and then you know he's bouncing
around like a real pro fighter and start
slamming leg kicks in on this guy you
see this guy's face like oh my god what
the [ __ ] have I signed up for he's just
some drunk [ __ ] and some dude dressed
like a Supergirl I I don't have any
sympathy for those people call I think
called himself Phoenix Jones I saw a guy
walking around dressed like a superhero
I'd be like that guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind and I would give him a wide
berth hoping he was on his way to his
place of solitude whatever that was ice
house way to the Batcave
I was younger yeah I might have you know
if I was standing in a crowd you know I
probably would have done some yeah punk
[ __ ] like that couple of whiskey's in
yeah oh yeah get my [ __ ] orange wig
slapped off yeah probably so Seattle is
on its run by a warlord someone [ __ ]
dude apparently according to my friend
was run who's a seal who's running this
entire seven block or six block area of
Seattle they spray-painted all the
windows on this yeah you know okay
talk to me in three days it's been going
on a lot longer than that it'll be fine
do you think so yeah that's gonna happen
do you think this war loads word Ethan
he's gonna have ten blocks and then 11
and then he's gonna take over all of
Washington I mean he's gonna run out of
men they have guns okay that's the
problem the problem is they're openly
carrying rifles inside this six block I
know what they need to eat okay and then
no supplies are gonna get in that seven
blocks they're just gonna wait them out
or they're gonna come in with superior
firepower it's not gonna end well Joe I
don't think it's getting in well I'm
just I don't you know how it's gonna end
all right let's let's sit let's guess
the scenario okay all right how many
bodies what's the over-under four people
died how many are there how many of them
are there thousands thank cows uns and
you're only going with four that's a
good number that's like a Vegas number
be like [ __ ] they must pick the perfect
I go over I go under this is right how
many [ __ ] people are in there but the
photos that I saw at the place is packed
filled with people like like they're
just getting out of a Chappelle show
look at this these are the people it
took city hall well
took City Hall they don't know now most
of them are white so I don't see the
staying power of this waiter what did
you say they opened the door for them
they gave them City Hall so this is City
Hall they're walking into right now yeah
well this is gonna be funny now when
they get in and they don't know what to
do let me hear some volume on this Jaime
only here what the [ __ ] they a love
Jamie Masada The Laugh Factory in Long
Beach got looted last night no God I
can't imagine how many puppets they took
[Laughter]
creepy [ __ ] mannequins that places oh
it's you know I love that place I love
performing there but some of the Jamie's
decor I love mine my favorite things to
doing this businesses [ __ ] on Jamie
Masada he knows I love him buddy bill
burr that black lives matter body don't
burn down my club
[Applause]